طيب احمد انت طلبت من زوجتك بانه بامكانها
انه تتبرع ولا الفكره ما كانت بالحسبان
بالاول
ولا لانها كانت ضعيفه يعني شكلها كده
نحيفه
وظيفه وكنا الحاله بتاعتي كانت ميؤوس منها
وكنا بنقول انه نحن عايزينها تبقى علشان
العيال
يعني تربي عيالها كنا خايفين عليها وكده
يعني
حتى العيله عندنا رفضت قال خليها انت
انتهيت كده
وخلي الوليه رب العيال
لكن هي اصرت انها تتبرع
والحمد لله ربنا كلنا بالنجاح طيب احمد
انت لجات لمقربين لالك ورفضوا ممكن تقول
لنا شو كان موقفهم شو كان تبريرهم وانت
كيف اتعملت مع هذا الموقف
تبريرهم ان الدكاتره بيتعلموا فيكم
وزرعاته خلصان وحالتك منتهيه خالص وتعبانه
[موسيقى]
لان الحاله الصحيه كانت تعبانه جدا
واستسقى كبير عالي
وصحه تعبانه خالص يعني لك ان تتخيلي مش
كنت قادر اكل حبات طعميه او شويه فول كنت
بروح مطعم الفول وطعميه ده اشم ريحه بس
لكن ما اقدرش اكل حاجه خالص صحيا تعبان
جدا
فمدام هي اللي وقفت جنبي بس لكن ما لقيتش
اي حد من القرايب ولا من هنا ولا من هنا
ولا اي حاجه خالص